One of the things that has just blown me
away in the last year,
because I've talked to lots of people,
lots of people live,
you know,
but also lots of people online,
but it's more obvious live and it's
obvious in this theater as well,
is that I've,
I've,
I've gone around and spoken and a large
proportion of my audience has been young
man,
you know,
under 30,
something like that and I've spoken to
them a lot about responsibility and
what's so odd about about this is that
of all the things that I've spoken about
because I can see the audience and I can
feel how the audience is reacting
because I'm always paying attention to
all of you.
It's in so far as I can manage that.
So I get some sense of how what I'm
saying is landing.
You know,
which you have to do if you're going to
speak effectively to people and what.
What happens is if I talk about
responsibilities,
everyone b is silent just like they are
now silent and,
and not moving,
right?
Focusing attentive,
say pick up your responsibility,
pickup the heaviest thing you can and
carry it and the room goes quiet and
everybody's eyes open and I think that
who making me break up,
I was.
I don't,
I don't know why I was speaking to an
English journalist today.
You're just going to write an article in
Spectator magazine.
I was talking about this and at the same
point in the discussion the same,
I had the same emotional reaction.
I don't really understand it.
It's.
I think it's something.
There's something about it that's so
crucial because you know,
we've been fed this unending diet of
rights and freedoms and there's
something about that,
especially if there's something about
that that so pathologically wrong and
people are starving for the antidote.
And the antidote is truth and
responsibility,
right?
And it isn't,
it isn't because that's what you should
do in some,
you know,
some,
some I know better or someone knows
better for you what you should do sense.
It's that.
It's that,
it's that,
it's that that's the secret to a
meaningful life and without a meaningful
life,
then all you have is suffering.
And,
and nihilism and despair and all of
that,
and self contempt and that's not good,
and so the man hits necessary for men to
stand up and take responsibility and
they all know that and and are starving
for that message and the message is more
that that's also a good thing to stand
up and take responsibility because
you're cursed so much now,
from,
from when you're young with this notion
that your active engagement with the
world is part of what is destroying and
undermining the planet and adding to the
tyranny of the social systems.
It's like,
how about not so much that,
hey,
because it's instant,
it's,
it's to soul deadening.
It's andy human right to the core and my
sense instead is that,
you know,
if you,
if you were able to reveal the best of
yourself to you in the world,
that you would be an overwhelming force
for good.